la nouvelle est tombée ce matin à Lille
les risques bien de secouer encore
davantage la France insoumise quatre
mois de prison avec sursis c'est la
peine à laquelle a été condamnée le
député du Nord de la France insoumise
Adrien catenin en plus de ses quatre
mois de prison avec sursis le député
Adrien catenens vient aussi d'être
condamné à verser 2000 euros de dommage
et intérêts après une plainte déposée
par son ex-femme il a été condamné ce
jour pour le fait de gifle qui la
reconnu et des faits de SMS réitérer à
l'envers de son épouse avant cette
audience à huis clos l'homme politique
en pleine procédure de divorce a été
accueilli par des militants très
clairement sa démission
démission si la France insoumise a
décidé de le suspendre pour une durée de
4 mois sa démission ne semble pas à
l'ordre du jour personne considère que
tout hypothèse de retour est impossible
alors Adrien catenins condamné à 4 mois
de prison avec sursis doit-il
démissionner de ses fonctions
qu'on cherche à minimiser ce qu'il a
fait en fait c'est de la prison mais
avec sursis il quitte la nuit Pesse mais
il va revenir comme s'il le fait de s'en
prendre physiquement à une femme c'était
pas si grave que ça que ça faisait
partie de la vie d'un couple moi je
pense qu'il faut une soirée exemplaire
vous imaginez si ça avait été dans un
autre parti
où ils expliquent qu'ils ont pris que
décisions de suspendre les modalités
suivantes retour dans le groupement
alimentaire 4 mois voilà et avec un
stage de responsabilisation sur les
violences faites aux femmes auprès
d'association féministe
leur communiquer parce qu'en fait ils
ont le même agenda que ce qu'a dit la
justice c'est-à-dire 4 mois avec sursis
ils font quatre mois avec sursis et ils
préparent son retour quand on lit les
tables de communiquer et est-ce qu'ils
ont déclaré aujourd'hui
très franchement avec toutes les
conneries qui font la France insoumis je
commence à me comprendre pourquoi ils
veulent désarmer la police
honnêtement honnêtement pour moi un il
ne peut pas revenir et de il doit
démissionner vous avez fait ça avec
cette sanction c'est impossible de
rester député donc il devrait
démissionner représenter se représenter
face à ces élections dans le Nord et
voir ce que les électeurs en pensent
mais on ne peut pas avec ce qu'il a fait
ce qu'il a reconnu hein bien sûr on ne
peut pas continuer comme si de rien
n'était lui non plus ils sont partis non
plus c'est impossible impossible vous
imaginez si un jour il a commenté une
loi sur les violences conjugales sa voix
n'est plus audible c'est c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible qu'est-ce
que tu en penses
de bien merci j'aime bien mais dans
quelle émission
en fait il doit démissionner il peut
plus rester parce que tu as dit et en
plus il porte beaucoup le des on défend
le droit des femmes et tout ce qui est
génial et après lui et il doit se
représenter
il se représente devant les gens et les
gens vont décider en politique le peuple
ou pas s'il peut pas rester politique
ces conneries voilà parce que c'est vrai
c'est insupportable oui bébé oui 4 mois
avec sursis on s'est implacable vous
l'avez tous 10 la parole est inaudible
c'est complètement confisqué aujourd'hui
parce qu'il est arrivé donc évidemment
il doit un démissionner éventuellement
se reprendre se remettre sans remettre
au suffrage universel et puis après on
verra bien après il peut être tout à
fait ré lui il y a des élus qui ont été
condamnés par la justice représentée qui
ont été élus parce que après tout même
si je condamne toutes ces idées
politiques il a le droit aussi à une
seconde chance
pour moi c'est comme si il partait en
vacances donc je pense que c'est bah
ouais quand on l'arrête 4 mois c'est
comme si tu partais en vacances et
qu'après tu revenais donc moi je suis
d'accord avec Valérie en fait j'aimerais
qu'il se représente et que ce soit le
peuple qui décide d'ailleurs il devrait
exister des sondages où on demande plus
au peuple en fait il faut savoir que
donc c'était une émission c'était une
procédure où il a plaidé coupable et
quand le procureur lui a proposé énoncé
la sanction qu'il pouvait accepter ou
non il a été abasourdi c'est-à-dire que
lui-même ça attendait à prendre une
amende cette sanction quand même elle
est très forte alors je vais vous dire
moi je pense qu'il y a énormément de
loubards là actuellement
dans le Groupe LSI
je vous dis je commence c'était c'était
des mecs je commence à avoir peur
et que c'était un vrai homme pur et dur
il partirait de lui-même un moment donné
tu t'arrêtes en fait c'était il y a
comme à Dijon comme indigent toi
excuse-moi comme a dit Guillaume il y a
des choses qui sont pas exclusables tu
as frappé ta femme tu te barres c'est
tout alors il s'est exprimé regardez
dans la préface
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pendant trois mois je me suis tue j'ai
réservé ma parole à la justice car j'ai
compris que seule l'enquête rétablirait
les faits en plus de l'épreuve
personnelle j'ai enduré en silence un
lynchage médiatique inédit de la part de
gens qui n'étaient pas derrière les
portes closes d'une histoire de couple
et qui ne connaissait rien au dossiers
la justice a pourtant écarté les
accusations de violences répétées et de
harcèlement et a décidé de ne pas me
renvoyer devant un tribunal pourquoi il
a arrêté alors
de la République il s'agit d'un
avertissement solennelle je prends ma
juste part mais je refuse d'en prendre
davantage et de continuer à subir cet
acharnement disproportionnée c'est la
raison pour laquelle je prends la parole
donc
voilà il prend la parole il dit que il
veut bien prendre sa part mais pas plus
alors
il dénonce sa femme dit lorsqu'on m'a
annoncé
son intention de divorcer autour de en
vacances d'été et que j'en cherchais la
véritable raison quelqu'un qui appelle
non mais attends
c'est Laurent là l'agent immobilier
rappelle mais c'est pas un travail
calme-toi je te jure fais gaffe je t'ai
déjà cassé beaucoup de choses
qu'on m'a annoncé son attention de
divorcer au retour de nos vacances d'été
et que j'en cherchais la véritable
raison mon ex se compagne m'a
ouvertement menacé de détruire mon
engagement politique si je ne répondais
pas favorablement à toutes ces exigences
elle m'a même fait signer un papier
l'affirmant sous la contrainte
aujourd'hui encore dans le cadre de
notre divorce et des conditions de la
gare de notre fille je suis suivi son
chantage en chantage à la plainte et aux
médias alors là il prend des risques
énormes au-delà de de la honte de
d'accabler ça son épouse parce que il
faut se souvenir que la première fois
elle avait très vivement réagi quand il
avait dit que c'était dans le cadre de
querelle de couple elle avait dit pas du
tout c'est répéter depuis des années ce
qui lui avait fait mal politiquement là
elle était à l'audience avec un avocat
ce matin maintenant on va contente de
voir si elle s'exprime et ce qu'elle a à
dire là-dessus alors si vous nous
rejoignez Adrien katnase donc on va
rappeler à quoi il est condamné il est
condamné à quatre mois de prison avec
sursis à 2000 euros d'amende à payer
à son niveau de son et au niveau de son
parti suspendu 4 mois exactement du
groupe parlementaire c'est-à-dire la
même durée de sanction puisque très
avril il donne des détails sur son
couple qui n'allait pas bien du tout à
la fin j'ai tout fait pour tenter de
sauver notre couple consenti tant
d'efforts et accepter des choses
inacceptables pour payer mon erreur
d'être parti pendant 2 mois par exemple
je devais sonner chaque soir pour
pouvoir accéder à mon domicile et je
devais me rendre seul avec ma fille aux
événements familiaux en père célibataire
et il accuse le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald darmin les mecs qui font des
conneries
ah c'est sorti tu es tranquille tout le
monde le gars voilà bah c'est comme ça
les mecs voilà c'est évidemment
politique un député moins visible
nourrissant doute pas fait l'objet du
même traitement
était trop belle pour abattre le
principal porte-parole et coordinateurs
de la France insoumise
contre-ordantes me disent que cela a été
directement orchestré depuis le
ministère de l'Intérieur donc c'est lui
qui a appelé Safa je ne suis pas en
mesure de la fermer moi-même aujourd'hui
ce qu'il y a de certains romans c'est
que si rapide efficace et très sélectif
les mecs ça c'est c'est quoi ça la
communication la plus catastrophique qui
sort une vieille théorie du complot il
sort la carte du lynchage médiatique à
aucun moment il parle d'effet mec tu as
giflé ta femme en fait il est en fait il
a aucun mais c'est ça concrètement il va
continuer d'être payé il va retrouver
son travail il va pas aller en prison
moi je pense qu'il faudrait une sanction
exemplaire c'est un homme qui a frappé
sa femme tu frappe une femme tu es une
merde c'est tout parce que Sandrine
Rousseau qui ne fait pas partie du
gouvernement et qui n'est pas pro
Darmanin a demandé sa démission elle a
été beaucoup plus dure avec lui que moi
j'ai une pensée pour sa femme il a giflé
en privé et là il l'a gifle publiquement
une deuxième fois et ça c'est scandaleux
vraiment et Guillaume a raison l'appel
d'air il est terrible ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui tu peux gifler et tu
prends 4 mois avec sursis tu peux mettre
une droite à ta femme tu prends 4 mois
avec sursis et il y a un expliqué sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est une prise de
parole de Jean-Luc Mélenchon du débat du
premier tour de la présidentielle 2017
et regardez et c'est vrai que ça pose
problème oui on peut prendre des mesures
d'abord il y en a de près
d'association anticorps a produit depuis
longtemps tout un ensemble de
propositions moi je les appliquerai
toutes et déjà je peux vous dire
quelques-unes d'entre elles quiconque
est condamné une seule fois et
inéligible à vie
rideau
c'est lui qui l'a dit
là c'est de ma faute quand l'autre il a
minuit face à femme c'est la faute du
ministre de l'intérieur c'est quand même
et quand c'est voilà mais là il a raison
Mélenchon
on va voir on va voir mais ils sont dans
une merde noire